what's prayer but if I'm aiming from
infinitive and today as you might see
we're doing some Christmas trick shots
hope you enjoy
first of all Christmas is nothing
without the Christmas tree and a
Christmas tree is nothing without some
decorations so let's decorate the tree
[Music]
okay so the Christmas tree is now
decorated it looks pretty nice I think
let's take a closer look
[Music]
next we need to light up the Christmas
candles and to make this process a bit
more interesting
let's lightly match table tennis shot
and then light the candles
[Music]
the star
[Music]
I find myself wondering downtown no
shopping
listen to the sound from some street
crier
Carolyn through the air
ginger cookies are really good but how
many of them is it possible to crush
with one table tennis shot I think the
right answer is maybe three but let's
find that out
[Music]
I find myself wandering downtown
[Music]
some street cry
[Music]
[Music]
okay this is creating such a mess on the
floor so it's better to stop here but
apparently it's possible to hit even
more than fire so maybe I'll try it out
sometime in the future you know this
Christmas elf looks like it would like
to play some table things so let's make
that happen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
always when you're lighting candles you
have to remember to put them out so you
can probably guess what I'm going to do
next but I'm going to do it with two
consecutive shots
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hope you guys enjoyed this video it was
a lot of fun making it
and if you want to see more videos
please leave this video a thumbs up and
if you're new to the channel subscribe
right here and watch the previous
episodes here happy holidays
[Music]